what do you think about like the the
flip side do you admire somebody like uh
Conor McGregor who
it knows how to create a spectacle you
Craig who likes spectacles spectacles
yeah I mean I really admired early Conor
McGregor because I found him absolutely
hilarious you know like I felt like that
was Peak Banta I feel like he just took
the American World by storm Aussies
British Irish kiwis I believe we have a
way better level of banter and attacking
each other and it's almost too easy to
pick on Americans to take themselves
very seriously I mean I keep believing
other parts of the world too the Far
East of Europe you know but that's
that's the tricky thing with Connor I
think he was I feel like you could have
gotten in the same kind of trouble
because the Russians really took
everything very seriously they weren't
joking around yeah that's that's the
problem it's like it's it's it's a bit
of a I mean some things he definitely
takes too far you know but I felt like
early on he had the right balance where
he wouldn't really cross a line but he
would do he would do enough he just took
it to another level obviously later in
his career
but I think early on a bit of innocent
better it gets a lot of eyes on the
sport though it's probably by far the
most popular combat athlete of all time
because of that yeah I feel like you
have to cross the line I don't think
enough people appreciate like the values
he's brought by crossing the line he's
making a sacrifice crossing the line
that's going to affect him for the rest
of his life you know
I see I don't think so I think you can
always walk back because I think unlike
where people might disagree with this
ice well yeah I I thought he always
radiated a respect
for the opponent like afterwards and
underneath it it felt like the same way
you do it when I hear you [__] talking I
don't see a person who really means it
I see a person who's having fun with it
I always saw Conor McGregor the same way
I don't know and but people took it like
extremely seriously but I I saw the
respect like the common respect the
martial artists have for each other that
felt like it was always there if you
don't like that individual you're gonna
perceive yeah what they say more uh
negatively than if you obviously were so
like I feel like if you like someone
you're gonna never think they really
cross the line that's true so you're
saying I like you must be your [__]
in a positive light is there are there
people that hate you
I mean some of the family members
people that really get to know you all
hate you the fans love me the friends
hate me it's a good place to be keep
your enemies close all right